let's go next to andrew from missouri
welcome andrew
yes hello hi can you hear me yes i can
excellent um so i am actually from the
ozarks in southwest missouri and i have
seen uh it's it's alarming to me uh in
the last year and well two years really
how many younger people have kind of
bought into the trumpest uh talking
points and just trumpism in general um
andy
um
to the point that it
it's one of those things where i worry
that we're not going to see this pass as
the older generation passes that would
that we're going to have to deal with
this for even longer and i'm just
wondering there's a couple points to
this uh
how do we combat this brainwashing of
the younger generations and like do
these do these hearings help with that
or are they gonna really or are they
just gonna be ignored by people who
already trenched and then with that do
democrats need to start playing the
unfortunately playing the political
theater game just to
just to get their their base
riled up to combat
trumpism
overall so i don't think that young
people are necessarily watching the
january 6th hearings in any
significantly large number so i wouldn't
count on that i actually have a
different perspective which is although
there are these young right-wing
movements like turning point usa
targeting people on college campuses
i actually think that the young folks
are the ones that have been least
brainwashed and the ones that were sort
of counting on so i don't see them as
the biggest problem to solve the you
know the older facebook conspiracy folks
seem like really the the problem
um but of course we want to make sure
that we're equipping young people with
tools so that they never become
indoctrinated in the first place
including critical thinking skills media
literacy etc
yeah yeah and it's it's it's one of
those
those things where are we
i don't know it feels like
the right has such a stranglehold on
controlling the narrative that
that i don't know how we can combat that
effectively that because they've been at
it for so long
i agree with you and i've talked about
all of the things that need to happen
it's the ones i already mentioned here
also the left needs to be as good and as
committed as the right to funding groups
that are working to grow the movement
the right just throws money at it they
don't care they won't stop and it's part
of why they succeed
yeah yeah hey real quick andrew before
you go can you name four countries that
start with the letter g out of curiosity
uh four countries to start with the
letter g yeah uh
we got georgia germany ghana and
[Music]
that's embarrassing well we i would have
accepted greece or guatemala greece
greece oh thank you yeah there we go all
right andrew thank you for the call i
appreciate it
thank you very much you have a good one
all right you too all right guys let's
take a very quick break we're taking
more calls so don't hang up if you're
holding on we're going right back to the
phones in a moment
many of us know what it's like to have
acne show up when we least want it to
you should have seen me in middle school
now i'm on camera and i really do the
best i can to keep my skin clear and for
that i go to apostrophe our sponsor on
the apostrophe website you just answer a
few questions take a couple pictures of
your skin and then you have a virtual
visit with a board certified
dermatologist who will create a
personalized treatment plan they quickly
ship you the prescription medication i
can tell you that when it comes to acne
you're better off with a dermatologist
there are all sorts of different kinds
of acne that need different types of
treatment the over-the-counter stuff was
not what worked for me
apostrophe makes it simple and quick
i've had a great experience with
apostrophe myself you get affordable
quality medical treatment from a
licensed dermatologist and prescription
meds that actually work but i can do it
all on my phone i don't have to spend
hours in a doctor's office
my audience gets 15 off your first
dermatology visit go to apostrophe.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is in the description